premier vrai maître gims ou alors à très
bas prix la table la wilaya de guelma et
bien regardez c'était vous dire on va
faire une cabine à grand bluff
ensemble avec patrick avec eelv à la
cabine qui est là venez me rejoindre et
il y a c'est une cabine un petit peu
spécial aujourd'hui puisqu'il ya patrick
sébastien bon line beaucoup vous allez
voir première cabine
elie vous allez regarder ce que vous
voyez dorian je vous dis ce que je vois
voilà exactement
et moi je vais devoir c'est la vérité ce
que je vais pas je sais pas je ne sais
pas où vont dire si qui dit la vérité
attention c'est parti ok donc là je vois
renault en vain de faire la vidange de
sa renault au nom trappeur nous ont fait
la vidange de sa renault
moi je vous dire je vois florent pagny
qui est avec une plante et qui chante ma
liberté de plants & animals yadir et
bien elie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
année
sa fille
c'est fou et le yoga question elle dit
bah c'est un sosie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être là en tout cas est franchie
à tous c'est top
eh bien tu es ce que tu vois deuxième
cas minable moi je vois francis cabrel
pas qui fait quoi
il est en train de répéter les sardines
d'accord et lis tu veux voir un truc 1 à
10 moi je vois pas un homme je vois une
femme
ouais ouais bah ouais y'a un problème ça
va toi la moustache mais attend un an je
vois nabila qui lit un livre je vois
maître gims qui fait de la gym donc
mettre au gym qui fait de la gym 3 words
in game ça va être long et wiggins pas
toi qui m'as dit à la barre ils
assistent anne francis la cdc ont bien
brûler m gates ou alors à très bien mais
là il me semble ce qui tempère il a qu'à
mon avis la ville avec amour et bien
regardez c'était
merci m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
scénographe
franchement c'est le cas ça va quitter
bercy et merci d'être là je vois tu vois
je vois moi ouais je vois patrick
sébastien qui manger une choucroute avec
des sardines encore elie ok moi je vois
michel drucker way qui pédalent bassin
plat de semoule occupée d'al dans la
souris dalle dans la semoule
je croquais structure qu'il peut vendre
le riz caire un trek la ccc de la
choucroute spa de la science et de la
semoule
j'ose dire choucroute moi je vois fabio
salsa le coiffeur qui fabbro shing un
sosie de valérie bénaïm away
alors avant comme un truc air dockers
bloquaient un truc c'est que c'était
patrick
[Applaudissements]
shell
[Musique]